PROFESSOR: Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
So in this problem,
I'd like to take
a look at autonomous
equations and phase lines.
And specifically, we're going
to take a look at the simple
equation x dot
equals a*x plus 1,
which models births and death
rates and a fixed replenishment
rate for a population.
So in this case, the
variable a represents births
minus deaths in a population.
And 1 represents the constant
input of new creatures.
So for part A, we're
asked to find intervals
of the variable
a which determine
the long-time stability
of the population.
And then secondly,
for each typical case
of a in the first
part of the problem,
we're asked to
sketch a phase line
and then also to sketch the
solution x of t versus t.
So I'll let you take a
look at this problem,
and I'll be back in a moment.
Hi Everyone.
Welcome back.
So the problem we're looking
at is x dot equals a*x.
And as mentioned in the
title of the problem,
this is an autonomous
equation which
means that the right-hand side
is not a function of time.
The right-hand side
only depends on x.
And for these types of
problems, the critical points
or the points at which
the right-hand side vanish
tend to determine the
long-time characteristics
of the solution.
So we can kind of get a
handle on what intervals of a
determine the long-time
stability by sketching what
x dot versus x might look like.
And we see that
if a is positive,
this represents a line
with a positive slope a.
So on the right-hand side of
the intercept with the x-axis,
x dot is positive, which means
that when the line goes through
the point x dot equals 0, the
term a*x plus 1 is going to be
positive.
I'll just point out that
this point right here
is when x dot is equal to 0.
And this happens when x is
equal to negative 1 over a.
So this point right here
is negative 1 over a.
And when x is below
negative 1 over a,
x dot is negative, which
means that solutions
will want to move away from
the point negative 1 over a.
What other qualitative
behavior could we have?
Well, when a is below 0,
when a is less than 0,
the slope of this curve
is going to be negative.
So I'll plot again
x dot versus x.
And again, the intercept is
going to be at negative 1
over a.
However, when x is above
the critical point,
x dot is negative.
So solutions will want to tend
to move back towards negative 1
over a.
And when x is below
the critical point,
we see that x dot is in
the upper plane, which
means it's positive.
So solutions will want to grow.
So we have two cases right now.
One is when a is bigger than 0.
One is when a is less than 0.
And then, of course,
there's going
to be an intermediate point,
which is when a is equal to 0.
And in this case, the
curve x dot versus x,
it's just going to be a straight
line hat goes through 1.
So this gives us three
regions that will determine
the long-time behavior.
So the three regions are
a equals 0, a less than 0,
and then a bigger than 0.
So this concludes part
A. And for part B,
we're asked to investigate the
behavior of each of these three
regions by constructing
a phase line,
and then, secondly, by
sketching a solution
or several solutions.
So for part B, let's take
a look at the case when
a is bigger than 0 first.
And I'm just going to
pick one value of a.
I'll just pick a is equal to 1
to work things out concretely.
And we're asked to
sketch a phase line.
So plot the phase line x here.
And we know from the ODE
that the critical point
occurs at negative 1 over a.
So in this case, there's going
to be one critical point,
and it's going to
be at negative 1.
Now when x is bigger
than negative 1,
we've already seen that x
dot is going to be positive.
So when x is bigger than
negative 1, in this region,
x dot is positive.
So above negative 1,
x dot is positive,
which means that if
a solution starts
at a point above
negative 1, it's going
to constantly increase forever.
And likewise, if it's
below negative 1,
it's going to decrease forever.
So this is x dot is
negative in this region.
And of course, x dot is 0
at the critical point, which
means if we start at
the critical point,
we stay there for all time.
So let's sketch some solutions.
So whenever I have to sketch
solutions for a phase line,
the first solution
I always plot is
going to be the critical point.
So note that x equals negative
1 solves the differential
equation.
So x equals a critical point
always solves the differential
equation.
So that means when x
is equal to negative 1,
we solve the
differential equation.
When x is bigger
than negative 1,
we attain exponential growth.
And when x is less
than negative 1,
we have exponential growth
in the opposite direction.
So this is sometimes said to
be an unstable critical point,
because any small perturbation
away from negative 1
will make the solution diverge.
Also note that once I
have one of these curves,
I can generate all the others by
just picking it up and shifting
it over.
And the reason this works is
because the original equation
is autonomous, meaning that
the right-hand side didn't
depend on time.
So whenever you have
an autonomous equation,
when you sketch
one solution, you
can always get the
others by just picking--
or you can always get
a family of others
by picking up that solution and
just shifting it to the right
and to the left.
Now when a is below
0, I'll just pick
the value of a
equals negative 1,
we have a critical point at 1.
And in this case,
the arrows are going
to point towards 1 like this.
And again, I can
sketch some curves.
So I'll first draw the
solution when x is equal to 1.
And in this case,
solutions are going
to converge towards
the critical point.
And in this case, we say that
the critical point x equals 1
is stable.
And that's because any small
perturbation in the solution
will eventually just come back
to the critical point at x
equals 1.
And now lastly, we
have the third case
which is when a equals 0.
And in this case, there
are no critical points.
In fact, x dot was equal to 1.
So x dot is positive
for all values of x.
So our phase line is
just a line with arrows.
And in this case, if I were
to sketch some solutions,
I'll just draw my axes, x and
t, there are no critical points.
X is just increasing.
So the solutions are going
to look something like this.
They're just going to be a
family of straight lines.
So we've just sketched
some phase lines,
and we sketched several
solutions for each phase line.
We've seen how the critical
points and the arrows
around the critical points
affect the long time
behavior of the solutions.
And this is
typically the process
that you go through when
looking at autonomous equations.
You always first, A, find
the critical points, then B,
find the regions between
the critical points
and figure out if x dot is
either positive or negative.
And then that automatically
gives you the phase line.
Once you have the phase line,
you can always just sketch
a family of solutions.
So I'd like to conclude here.
And I'll see you next time.